[Music]
before creation itself there were six
singularities
forged into Infinity stones
this is our first day here we are in
Pinewood in Atlanta and it's it's
actually pretty unbelievable
day one of what promises to be a year of
fun-filled lensing I remember actually
going to see the first Avengers with one
of my best mates from home and I'd never
have dreamed that I'd ever be in one of
these movies let alone playing
spider-man I feel like I'm on top of the
world because this is just mind-blowing
what we always try to do at marvel
studios is we're building the cinematic
universe is look at the big picture how
can things relate across movies and
across years Avengers infinity war is
the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe has started in May of
2008 with the release of Iron Man 1 and
it really is an unprecedented
culmination of a series of films
interlinked together which it's time had
never been done before and for us the
important thing is making it all come
together we know they're gonna face
Thanos we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 how do you do that in a way
that is unexpected that pits the
Avengers against somebody who's more
powerful than aim when they face and yet
make them completely unprepared to face
him well tear them apart which is why we
did Civil War before infinity war as we
were conceiving in executing civil war
the end of that movie was very much a
setup for what these movies would be we
always had that sense of that
tony is not talking to Steve the
Avengers are basically a name with
nobody in it the world is vulnerable
Tony
senses his greater threat approaching
and so he is doing everything in his
power to keep the earth safe
thanos shows us why he's the biggest the
best the baddest villain that we've ever
had and the most frightening villain
that the Avengers have ever faced the
most exciting part is the incredible
roster of well developed characters and
that's going to create a really
combustible exciting massive scale
adventure
as promised sorry we're running a little
late you know night shooting at all hey
guys I'm here on the set of Avengers
infinity Wars god this movie is gonna be
so epic
it's so big in fact that I had to up my
game a bit for this one so I got my own
camera guy just follows me around the
set saying how the fans camera guy so
today I'm here to answer your questions
all right
Facebook what do you got for me so what
excites you most about being back with
the Avengers well I can't give too much
away but I mean this literally feels
like the second greatest story ever told
and there's so many characters and so
much interesting stories so many
surprises and if you could have any
other Iron Man armor which one would you
like to take from the set I still fondly
remember the mark 42 from Iron Man 3
excellent question
keep it rolling and are you in Captain
America still not getting along that is
correct
he's on my s list I'm blowing through
these I mean wow let me keep going where
are the rest of these questions oh here
the questions camera guy is struggling a
little bit
what has changed most about playing Tony
Stark's since the first Ironman um well
I guess he's matured a little bit and I
think what's changes the universe around
him honestly if you think about it right
I mean there's so many offshoots now
Peter Parker's in the mix guardians are
on fire what's your favorite thing about
waking up and playing Ironman
you know there's a certain credit I
don't deserve I'm definitely not as cool
as he is but sometimes I look in the
mirror and I go just just keep it Tony
and everything's gonna be all right
hey hey oh my god that's great Joe and
Anthony Russo I know you guys are ready
but I'm doing a little thing here I'm
taking some questions from the fans at
Facebook like say hello to the world
they're running this whole dog and pony
show some Facebook are you aren't you
our cameraman on set I no no he's my guy
no no no why don't we just move on we
recognize that guy camera man we got a
shot going on inside many Avengers which
one would you be
I'm sorry what was that yes so what
would you be good eye big ants good at
answering this question what's your
answer for this one that would be our
cameraman
this is my guy he's just a he's just a
up stories uh you know it's like an
intern you just let's answer that
question always is pizza good
yeah you guys could take Avengers on a
family vacation who would you take three
Avengers on a family vacation I mean we
have to say start because he's here yeah
yeah we're work you could go anywhere
would start what we say would you take
Peter Parker you know estranged feel I
could offer you a bunch of destinations
right wormhole in it I guess I'm not too
familiar with what he's up to
be a great value on family vacation hmm
powers whose abilities would serve like
vision with opening on beach umbrellas
yeah yeah yeah vision putting up a
two-man tent makes it more sensible yeah
right and since you two were brothers do
you guys ever argue on set when you're
directing Neverland is that have you
ever witnessed a fight between us right
I have not I have not even seen the
mildest of tensions
hey thanks for all the great questions
yes but we got it ready I'll fit in the
room yes but what are on these script
pages I mean these pages right here yeah
let me do it
this final page of the screenplay is
that it says the end right here at the
bottom oh my god what is freezing oh no
no no don't wait don't face it okay all
right
all right thanks thanks are you kidding
me thank you thank you you know what I
will take just one one more question
yeah we are we have someone here wanting
to ask whether spider-man will be in
this movie can you answer that one I
don't know if I can say I will Punk that
one to my camera guy it's pretty safe to
say that he's gonna be in the movie
we're gonna have a lot of fun
okay Facebook there's one little nugget
for you I got to go before I let
anything else you know
out of the bag and what's huh what's up
hey oh shoot man it's Friday night yeah
yeah what do they call mr. set yeah they
caught us it what are you doing oh
nothing just a little Facebook live you
don't Facebook live yeah it's taking
questions don't tell me we were is there
any questions for me
hey everybody is Charlie just emergency
post Robert Downey jr. surprised
everyone saying hey I have a special
announcement to make so he just waxes
gets really funny about Avengers
infinity war excited about filming it
but then throws to his quote-unquote
camera guy who is spider-man himself Tom
Holland confirming his presence in the
film everybody was wondering about it
this is probably the studio's way to
just come right out and say it look
everybody's wondering we saw a picture
of Tom Holland and a beanie earlier
today here he is and then Chris Pratt
star-lord walks in in costume just
confirming that he is also in the movie
so it is all cards on the table so new
round of the Marvel giveaway just
because this is so crazy all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll do a
follow-up video this weekend we can
freak out so everybody just go crazy in
the comments this is so awesome
so a whole bunch of stuff coming this
weekend is gonna be great